parmi les chroniqueurs on en parle
beaucoup de matches où il est
incontournable a déjà matthieu delormeau
il s'est fait chahuter un petit peu en
plateau depuis la rentrée mais en
coulisse court ça se passe tiens pour
mathieu voici la réponse les caméras du
poste de surveillance ont pu le suivre
une journée dans les loges de touche pas
à mon poste
un document exclusif de noémie laguna et
harley davidson
c'est à 17 heures devant les locaux des
huit que nous retrouvons la nouvelle
recrue de tpm p matthieu delormeau
le transfuge d'nrj12 salue tous ses
nouveaux collègues et salut les gars
salue la belle manon et bien sûr le
meilleur stadium s'est pas encore
optimale des amis quelqu'un peut
m'ouvrir c'est matthieu delormeau ne
sont pas rares l'humour canal super
merci à à moins de deux heures du direct
le jeune chroniqueur n'a pas une seconde
à perdre et rejoint ses collègues au
stylisme au deuxième étage deuxième
étage gros naze
les canards et les filles salue les
poteaux et top
bonne émission un bon gars cette
émission a c'est à dire vous adore ouah
je donnais tout brillants des nuls
j'adore l'esprit canal 18 heures la
préparation de l'émission bat son plein
mais mathieu a besoin de concentration
dans la loge que des 8 a mises à sa
disposition
son havre de paix un bain bien vu dans
ma loge c'est ici que je prépare mes
mais brillante intervention c'est la
simplicité on se prend pas la tête
thierry et même très gentil il a tout
mis à ma disposition
erika moulet après deux heures de show
la journée s'achève pour mathieu salut
tout le monde mais une bonne surprise
l'attend et il m'a dit m'a tiré dessus
merci beaucoup bon ben je crois que ça y
est les amis un fait partie de la grande
famille
waouh c'est con mais fémur ça fait
quelque chose
merci monsieur
vous inquiétez pas il est bien traité
matri le pot moi il m'a fait de la peine
dans le reportage s'organise oui sinon
françois mathieu c'est pas un reportage
quoi c'est de la fiction vraie vie des
vrais logements jeu mais c'est tout
court c'est vrai vous méprenez pas ce
que moi j'étais sûr que c'est vrai quoi
non car il vous a fait appel mais aussi
longtemps qu'il me fait de la peine
merci d'avoir joué le jeu merci n'a pas
joué beaucoup de plaisir voir tourner ça
il vous a donné un petit billet comme
non elle m'a rien donné on a passé un
très bon moment c'est un garçon que
j'aime beaucoup
bah écoutes je suis là tu touches pas
faire j'ai regardé s'ensuit la touche
pas